good morning
migration has always been a fact for
europe
and it will always be throughout
centuries
it has defined our our societies
and shaped many of our lives and this
will
always be the case migration is complex
the old system to deal with it in europe
no longer works the commission's package
on migration and asylum
which we present today offers a fresh
start many legitimate interests have to
be brought into balance
we want to live up to our values and at
the
same time face the challenges of a
globalized world
europe has to move away from ad-hoc
solutions
and put in place a predictable and
reliable
migration management system i'm
convinced that the commission's proposal
is a good foundation for that
this package reflects a fair and
reasonable balance between
responsibility and solidarity
among member states we all share the
benefits
we all share the burden this package
also reflects a very pragmatic and
realistic approach
we know that we have to build trust
among member states and
citizens confidence that we can manage
this
as a union the package reflects
the complexity of the issue as it brings
together
all aspects of migration border
management
and screening asylum and integration
return and relations with external
partners
and finally the commission's proposal
builds on the different geographical
situations
the different capabilities and choices
of european member states but also takes
into account that the pressure
on our borders is varying and this
results in a new balance
between responsibility and solidarity
it is not a question whether member
states should support
with solidarity and contributions but
how
they should support moria
is a stark reminder we need to find
sustainable solutions on migration and
we all have to step up
the european commission is ready to step
up as well
we want to provide rapid assistance
we will set up a joint pilot with the
greek authorities
in lesbos for the management of a
reception center
to implement this we decided on a task
force today
with the support of our eu agencies this
task force
will help improve conditions for people
on the island in a durable manner
together we have to show that europe
manages migration
in a humane and effective way
the european union has already proven
in other areas that it can take
extraordinary steps to reconcile
diverging perspectives we have created a
complex
internal market a common currency
and an unprecedented recovery plan to
rebuild our economies
it is now time to rise to the challenge
to manage migration jointly with the
right balance
between solidarity and responsibility
in a few minutes vice president skinas
and commissioner johansson
will present more detailed information
on the migration package
in the press room thank you
you